For this project you will need the printed copy of the template, scissors and tape.
Cut out the five strips on the dotted line.
Make sure to separate the co-joined strips.
The green, orange and yellow tabs have to remain attached to their respective strips.
Proteins are polymer chains of amino acid residues.
Each number on the model represents one amino acid residue.
Insulin has two chains. Chain A, is green Chain B is blue.
Tape together the two pieces of the A chain (green) so that residue 11 is back-to-back in the two pieces.
Tape together the three pieces of the B chain (blue) by overlapping the gray tabs at the ends, so that
all the numbers are visible on one side and all the numbers are in order.
Some sections of amino acid chains
curl and form alpha helices due
to hydrogen bonds between N-H and C-O groups.
The helix regions on the model are marked on the chains with darker shades of green and blue.
Starting with residues 1 and 5 form a hydrogen bond between C-O and N-H, and tape together.
Keep creating the hydrogen bonds until you reach the end of the darker colored area.
When you reach residue 6, make sure the green tab is on the outside of the helix.
Create another alpha helix starting with residues 17 and 21.
Keep creating hydrogen bonds until you reach the end of the darker colored area.
Starting with residues 7 and 11, form a hydrogen bond.
Keep creating the alpha helix until you reach the end of the darker colored area.
Some amino acids give a TURN to the chain.
The turns are marked on chain B of the
paper model with the white dashed lines.
Fold outwards on the white dashed lines to create the turns. You can secure the folds with tape.
Also note that chain B also includes a beta strand marked with a blue arrow.
The structure of Insulin is stabilized by 3 disulfide bridges.
A disulfide bridge is formed when a sulfur atom from the residue cysteine
forms a single covalent bond with a sulfur atom from a second cysteine.
The first disulfide bridge connects 2
cysteines in chain A. To form the bridge, connect the green tabs
Connect the yellow tabs, matching their shape while making sure the colored sides are facing the same way.
Connect the orange tabs matching their shape while making sure the colored sides are facing the same way.
Congratulations! If you have completed all the steps and your project looks like the one shown here, then you now have your own insulin model.